good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the government shutdown
is now entering its fourth week and
neither side has moved much the
president has been arguing for the past
three years that the United States needs
a wall on its southern border agree with
his positions or not Trump has explained
why he believes that repeatedly and
ingrates day almost recently in a live
address to the country Democrats
meanwhile have argued the opposite
America should not have a border wall
they've said again and again but the
difference is they really haven't
explained why at various times
Democratic leaders have told us that
walls don't work walls are racist walls
are wasteful walls are insufficient
walls are excessive and walls are too
old-fashioned walls are either medieval
or ancient depending upon who's reading
the talking point at the time some of
these arguments are semi-real others are
transparently fake still others flatly
contradict one another rhetorically the
Democratic case against walls has been a
mess from the beginning at one point
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi tried to
bring order to the chaos by flatly
declaring that walls are immoral she
recently she said that repeatedly with
the force of a religious edict which in
effect it was but in the end the
theology of it all was just too complex
it seemed to confuse people
how can walls be immoral if a lot of
those who oppose walls have walls around
their own homes that was a tough case to
make even for a persistent faith leader
like Nancy Pelosi finally plosives gave
up yesterday she accepted the
inevitability of a border wall but
here's the catch the hidden trapdoor in
the space-time continuum that Pelosi is
famous for in Washington yes Democrats
now support a border wall but no it's
not the kind of wall you had in mind the
kind of wall you can touch or the kind
of wall that might keep unwanted people
out of your country it is instead a
digital wall
it's a massive invisible edifice
constructed entirely of virtual ones and
zeros that reside in some Amazon server
farm somewhere in suburban Virginia it
is the wall of the future in other words
a wall that Google might build and
probably will Pelosi calls it a
technological wall we are proposing is
to build
infrastructure of the ports of injury it
strengthened that the ports of entry
spend the money is hundreds of millions
of dollars but accessible to have the
scanning technology to scan cars coming
through for drugs contraband of any kind
weapons even repair the roads of
facilitate immigration and trade in
those regions the positive shall we say
almost technological wall that can be
built is what we should be doing of
course a technological wall why don't we
think of that but way you say aren't all
walls technological walls the only
difference of course is in the kind of
technology they employ well yes but
before you get hung up on some semantic
point just be grateful that Pelosi is
using the W word at all there was a time
not so long ago when she was telling us
that a fleet of lawn mowers would be
enough to secure the border let's talk
about where that a more serious
structure might be necessary where
fencing will do or mowing the grass so
that people can't be smuggled through
the grass what a certain point you begin
to wonder if Democrats are really as
serious as they say they are about
wanting to secure our border maybe
you've asked yourself that question well
wonder no more
they are not interested officially
Democrats support our immigration crisis
which they will be quick to remind you
isn't actually a crisis at all but part
of the poem at the base of the Statue of
Liberty
Democrats main interest is in continuing
this status quo and they want to do that
by making certain that no effective
barrier is ever built along our southern
border to achieve that Democrats and
their faithful lackeys in the press will
say anything literally anything
yesterday to name but one among many
examples Democrat Katie Hill of
California member of Congress accused
the president of engaging in a form of
terrorism for disagreeing with her gets
more and more frustrating every single
day to see how irrational he is and
it's it's we can't accept this anymore
to me this is political terrorism
terrorism
maybe that's next week's talking point
check the sunday shows to see if it
makes an appearance there this week the
phrase was vanity project the wall
they're telling you is somehow the
president's vanity project like a
remodeled basement rec room or the
Clinton Presidential Library some
consultant thought up that line and
emailed it to Pelosi and Schumer who
made certain that every Democrat in
Washington included it in virtually
every publicly uttered sentence for a
period of at least 24 hours which of
course they were happy to do being
robots watch a construction brigade for
the president's vanity project doesn't
necessarily require our building of
vanity project concrete wall for one
thing this is a vanity wall the
president is holding it up because of
his vanity project the president united
states has a vanity project that he
doesn't want to give up spent on the
issues that impact them every day not on
the president's vanity project this
issue is about a vanity project for this
president a vanity well that's a new
concern in Washington as it turns out
vanity is actually the main reason the
left loves in mass immigration in the
first place
they let millions of poor people into
your country at your expense but they
get to feel like heroes for doing it
it's really the equivalent of forcing a
stranger to dump his wallet into the
collection plate at gunpoint and then
taking the tax deduction for it it's a
pretty great deal if you're the one
holding the gun in fact you might call
it the ultimate vanity project